guys the scam we're investigating today
took in over 20 million dollars
and their ceo the whole time was an
actor guys uh everyone knows if it
sounds too good to be true
it probably is and yet every year people
keep falling for it why well we know
desperation plays a large role covet
does
as well people are out of work looking
for a new way to make their
make money and one popular new method is
something called
a hype have you guys heard of this it's
called the high yield investment program
not spelled like
hype like spell like hype like this uh
this is always a ponzi scheme do not
believe it if somebody's claiming these
crazy returns
it's probably a scam the specific scam
we're talking about today
and investigating is barack's but these
are a dime a dozen in fact i interviewed
someone
who is addicted to these things and let
me tell you
people who fall for them are not who
you'd expect okay
it's not it's a lot of these people say
i never could have imagined myself
getting involved in this
i don't know what i was thinking we're
talking to bernard and perry today
and uh we'll be hearing from them a lot
of the people who invest in this stuff
they never saw themselves
investing with these things but they're
clever techniques used to trick you
into investing with these idiots so
first of all what is
the burex scam well burax was a website
that popped up that wanted to
imitate financial institutions um
offering
let's just say very uh speculative
returns 1.4 percent
a day and you could even get more than
that
if you invested more money now if you're
a long-time coffeezilla fan you know
that 1.4
a day doesn't exist but
if you're not if you're an average joe
who maybe doesn't spend all your days
laughing at scams
maybe you don't so let's take a deeper
dive and figure
out who borax claimed to be before it
all
came falling apart but before it
collapsed let's take a look at some of
their
promotional materials shall we and how
dynamically technologies are developing
in the modern world it would not be wise
not to apply them
in the field of automation of financial
analysis processes
in march 2018 our team for the first
time
allowed themselves to put their
management of multiple accounts
in the hands of a trading board
developed by
our specialist inspirational music check
sketchy russian accent check what do we
got buzzwords oops that's also
a check this looks credible right it's
well shot
it's a documentary this guy looks like a
ceo doesn't he he looks like someone who
would run
a big organization but the problem is
the claims are just too high 1.4 percent
a day
could not exist if it did you'd quickly
become the richest man in the world
there's no such thing as a guaranteed
return this was actually the hallmark
of one of the greatest scammers ever
bernie madoff and the hallmark of all
ponzi schemes is these steady
guaranteed returns that are super
attractive they don't really exist
and deep down you know it doesn't really
exist even the people that i talked to
the people who got scammed they even
told me you know i
i kind of maybe felt that something was
maybe off but uh you know it just
it just seemed like you know a good
chance for me to make some money if you
have even the twinge of
maybe this is it i don't know maybe this
isn't really real
get the hell out and after a few days of
successful operation of this boat we
were convinced
that we need to completely change the
concept of our walk
and after three months of break even
trading operations
we realized that we had made a huge
break for
in the field of exchange this is another
thing they say besides the buzzwords
they always talk about their journey how
they
found a great bot after years of work it
was failing then all of a sudden
it just worked it just works like magic
guys and it's never failed since
honestly they're not looking for your
average joe's money they're looking for
big boys
they want to talk to people with
billions of dollars or
millions of dollars not your five
thousand dollars so
the first big red flag of any kind of
investing
portal is if they're gonna give you high
returns
and you don't need much starter cash if
they're guaranteeing returns
and they're saying hey just invest ten
dollars twenty fifty dollars hundred
dollars
look real investors no offense don't
want
tiny fishes money they don't care about
you they want like the big dogs and it
makes sense right
why would you want to deal with twenty
thousand clients with five thousand
dollars instead of one client
with like 20 million dollars it doesn't
make yeah it's
just the numbers don't work out why
would you deal with that headache now
before you move on and talk about how
the ceo is a paid actor
let's first hear from our victims from
this scam this is bernard and perry
i initially made two deposits
the first one was one ethereum i believe
one ethereum at that time
was if i'm not mistaken around the 1500
range
in total at that time that i made those
two deposits it totaled out to
2.3 there but that's not that's like
four thousand dollars that's that's a
lot
exactly exactly the part of
understanding
why that happened to me is worth a lot
more
because i'm not gonna make that same
mistake going forward ladies and
gentlemen this is bernard he also lost
money
with the burrex scheme how much did you
lose bernard i lost around 23
at that time that's a lot
that's that's a serious amount of money
yeah i mean
i feel bad because some of my buddies
like i put in about
13 people in this thing so it was uh
it was a pretty sad day man when i had
to tell each individual
their money is gone because everybody
trusted my word
you know your word is your bond and when
i had to tell them like wait a minute
wait a minute you're telling me our
money's gone
and uh and there's 70 ethereum across
all the people 70 ethereum
yeah across my across my people it was
around
73 ethereum how much how much is that
73 ethereum i want to say 140 150
000 one ethereum now is two thousand
dollars
when we come across these type of
platforms unless they're like
legitimate i wouldn't just go the other
way
i'm not i know for back i'm not getting
myself into that same situation again
but yeah one percent a day walk the
other way
okay
now these losses are terrible but i
think it's worth
telling you guys that during those
conversations
i was really trying to hammer home the
idea that
these returns should have never been
considered credible
there's this idea that like maybe this
wasn't the right
investment vehicle in other words like
oh maybe this one doesn't work but
there is a legitimate hype out there and
the answer to that
like thought is no one percent a day
doesn't exist if it does it carries high
risk in all likelihood
if you can just get it in your head that
one person a day or anything close to
that just doesn't exist
you are going to do very well you're not
going to fall for these insane get rich
quick schemes so if you're one of these
people that thinks oh maybe i just need
to find the right one the right scheme
that does work
you're gonna get burned because these
guys are good at making themselves look
legit like
they'll oftentimes put um their address
somewhere it's not actually like
they'll pretend to be from somewhere
they're not so obviously the actor we
saw
is russian right but they put their
address in australia
why because people trust australia more
than they do
russia now this is the street view of
australia where they say
they're they're located in and of course
we can't find their building because it
doesn't exist
they also say they're registered in
australia which of course they're
absolutely not and that documentation
turns out to be
completely fake but the real cutting
edge innovation
is what i've been hinting to this whole
time the people supposedly
running the show are puppet actors
so take a look at this man and this work
was uncovered by behind mlm
look at this guy look familiar or
perhaps this guy this is an
actor profile this is the same man
that we see here posing as an investment
professional
for a ponzi scheme additionally the
cmo chief marketing officer was a girl
named
susan pope and 78 of the committed
trading transactions
she also went on many live streams mini
podcasts to talk
to shill this thing and she answered
questions like a good old pro
would bs artists saying all the things
they were doing
and you know just get generally giving
the impression this is a professional
organization
and i as a marketing director who was
directly involved in its
development can only confirm his words
so she gave many interviews
only it turns out her acting reel wasn't
covered she says
i am a student at the higher school of
performing arts
the same exact person this is not a
marketing person
this is an actor and people fell for it
now the sad thing is is that once these
people were outed as actors the ponzi
scheme
unfortunately of course collapses like
it was destined to
anyways and uh bernard and perry lost
their money and are very
unlikely unfortunately to get it back
because
unlike jay mazzini the people who set up
this scam didn't put their name on it
instead they just attached a bunch of
hired actors to it
but this is to let you know the lengths
these people will go to
there's so much money to be made by
scamming people
i mean it's the most despicable thing
you can do to another human being but
there's a lot of money in it
and so unscrupulous individuals will go
to any length to get this done
in total we saw wallets approach 20
million dollars total
from this scam that ran for less than a
year
less than a year and it had no
reputation no one had ever heard of this
before it ran
so in one year no reputation two paid
actors
20 million dollars if that doesn't give
you an idea at the length someone be
willing to go to get this kind of money
i don't know what could but let me tell
you guys they will go to this length and
farther to convince you that they're
legitimate and deposit money with them
and once you do
it's as good as gone once you transfer
cryptocurrency to somebody else's wallet
you've effectively said goodbye right
they they're saying
they're keeping your money if it's not
regulated if you don't have that money
insured
if it's not within your local
jurisdiction chances of you getting that
money back are basically
nothing which is horrible to say
and um overall you know the victims of
this they just want to see that no one
falls for this again
we knew the consequences we saw the red
lights but
we still went in this is our our own
mistake but
it's also a opportunity to prevent other
people from doing that same mistake as
well
i don't care if mark cuban himself
descends
from the dallas mavericks and tells you
to put your money with him you do not do
it
coffeezilla says no if if they're making
insane promises chances are
they're insane don't put your money with
them that's basically it hope you
learned some lessons today
thanks for watching um and uh that's
basically it i'll see you guys next time
wake up and smell the coffee